Keck Ich hab Dreck in meinem Wasserschwimmen, was ist das?
Irgendeine Mücke oder so, Monarch S, Dance Game, ah ja, so Leute es wird heut mal wieder
Zeit, die letzten China Chinesen Reserven müssen geflasht werden, moin Leute, ich komm
nicht vor die Kamera, Sekunde, hier, ja, hallo, hallo, hallo, weiß gar nicht wie ich gescheit
winken soll, so vielleicht, so, keine Ahnung, lull, so ich muss mal kurz die Kabel, das
Kabel an der Kamera weg machen, das ist da ziemlich störend im Weg, so, so, so, so,
und KS, kann der sich hier irgendwie hinsetzen oder so, so, ok, der ist schepp, so, hallo,
hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, habe ich unexpected zur Garage geguckt,
habe ich gerade schon doch mal das
什ellawine gesch germsft, die zum Beispiel habe ich dieseा
Teilzahnshür gelernt, monde hat immer eine constant, also, ja, ich dann bin aber dann
flaschen bis dann endgültig Schluss ist mit China flaschen weil die neuen
China-Chinesen-Geräte sind nicht mehr flashbar oder halt nur mit größeren
Umbauarbeiten oder gar nicht mehr weil komplett anderer Chip. Keine Chance
machst du nix. Moin Twitter, wat?
Du hast die von Hammer noch da. Hast die auch geflasht oder nicht?
Kleiner, mal kurz anderen Sound.
So was. Hast du schon mal was von Yeelight geflasht?
Nee. Yeelight. Kenn ich vom Namen her, sagt mir das irgendwas.
Ich vermute mal die machen RGB, WLAN-Lampen und LED-Strips. Würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten
vom Namen her, oder?
Aber sagt mir jetzt, also der Name sagt mir was, aber so noch nix mitgemacht.
Was war? Ich kann mich nicht erinnern. Habe ich heute irgendwas auf Twitter?
Twitter geschrieben?
Habe ich heute auf Twitter geschrieben? Nix, oder?
Irgendwas auf Twitter geschrieben heute? Ach so, ja die Sache mit der 1&1 Rechnung.
Die haben ja sogar darauf geantwortet, was ich besonders witzig fand. Das war ja
nix Schlimmes. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Sie schreiben die erst vor
einer Woche oder vor drei Tagen schreiben sie, ja Achtung, also Rechnungen kommen
jetzt nicht mehr per Mail und heute kriege ich die Rechnung per Mail. Schon
irgendwie ein bisschen widersprüchlich.
Weißt du noch was du für letzte Weihnachten sin via LEDs genommen hast?
Ja, da müsste ich nachgucken. Das Problem ist, ich bin jetzt aktuell Amazon nur
eingeloggt auf meinem Handy und mein Handy ist gerade da. Da kann ich nicht draufgucken.
Das Wetter eskaliert. Ja, deswegen habe ich
Themenanlage an. Ich überlege gerade, was war das denn? Das waren irgendwelche
irgendwas mit Fairylight oder so hießen die Dinger. Irgendwie Fairylight, LED, RGB
oder so. Sowas da in der Richtung war das. Ich kann jetzt leider nicht nachgucken,
aber sowas war was ganz billiges. Es waren auf jeden Fall nur 50 LEDs, glaube
ich, 50 LEDs für einen Meter. Also die waren relativ dünn bestückt, was halt den
Vorteil hatte. Du konntest die ganz gut wo lang legen, ja zum Beispiel auch in
Weihnachtsbaum. Also damit den Weihnachtsbaum so voll zu machen, musstest
dir irgendwie 30 solcher Ketten kaufen. Für den Weihnachtsbaum und wie gesagt
Treppenbeleuchtung habe ich damit gemacht. Ja, ich glaube sowas hier in der
Richtung war das. Allerdings halt nicht einfarbig, sondern RGB. Wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Müssen wir mal gucken, weil die sind ja auch nicht alle richtig steuerbar. Ich muss
nachgucken. Keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht machen gerade. RGB, Weihnachtsbaum, ja klar.
Meine LED-Ketten für den Weihnachtsbaum sind seit Jahren schon wie LED
gesteuert mit RGB. Mein Weihnachtsbaum ist 2022. Razor Templates, na ja, ich
persönlich mag es nicht sonderlich, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und Blazer ist ja
quasi Razor Templates. Halt im Browser, also ich mag ich persönlich mag es nicht
sonderlich. Wenn man aber.NET Server-Site-Rendern machen will. Nicht Strips,
sowas hier habe ich für Weihnachtsbaum. Guck mal, das sind keine Strips. Das sind,
die sind nur an so dünnen Drähten dran. Ich weiß nicht ob man das hier irgendwie erkennt.
Das sieht man hier gar nicht richtig. Guck mal, das sind keine Strips,
die sind die LEDs, sind an so dünnen Drähten dran und dann ist einfach so ein,
ja was ist denn das? Wahrscheinlich Billig-China-Chinesen-Heißkleber oder so,
der da drum gemacht ist. Nee, nee, das sind keine Strips.
Ja, also wenn du.NET Server-Site-Rendern machen willst, dann kommst du ja um Razor
Templates nicht wirklich rum. In beschränkter Maße zu benutzen, warum nicht?
Aber ich mache eigentlich immer nur die Kombination reines RP-Backend und dann
irgendeine reine Klein-Site-Anwendung. Wenn du jetzt natürlich irgendwas hast,
was auch von der Suchmaschine gefunden werden soll, dann ist es wieder was anderes.
Wobei selbst dann würde ich wahrscheinlich keine Razor Templates nehmen, sondern
irgendwas anderes Server-Site-Rendering-mäßiges, was zu meinem Frontend-Framework passt.
Ja, Blazer ist immer noch der heiße Scheiß bei Microsoft. Die ganzen neuen Sachen,
die bei ASP.NET reinkommen, sind irgendwie 80% Blazer-Kram. Ich persönlich, wie gesagt,
habe ich keine Ahnung. Was ist denn das für eine komische, was ist denn das für eine komische
Url? Piped. Das ist definitiv nicht meine YouTube Domain. Das replacet diese Seite,
oder? Keine Ahnung. Also die haben total viel neues. Ich bin aber kein Fan von Blazer. Ich
finde für WebAssembly eignet sich das so in der Art und Weise nicht richtig. Die laden ja auch
die komplette Runtime runter, anstatt das zu kompilieren und dann jittert das nicht mal
richtig. Das ist ganz, ganz komisch. Die letzten Reserven, ich habe nicht mal viel. Ich habe von
den Dingern hier, habe ich noch, also hier da, die da, habe ich noch keine Ahnung. Also ich habe
insgesamt vier Stück. Jetzt noch zum Flaschen. Drei im Schrank, eins da. Eines ist hier abgeraucht,
eine liegt noch da hinten. Danach ist weg. Aber das reicht ja auch an Steckdosenleisten. Wir
brauchen nicht jeden Tag neue Steckdosenleisten. Aber ich habe mir gedacht, solange wir die jetzt
rumliegen, es wird mal Zeit, die langsam aber sicher zu flaschen. Übrigens, Leute, jetzt
wollen wir gerade dabei sein. Ich muss euch mal was zeigen. Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz,
mach mal kurz. Big Gatschi-Buzz. Schaut mal. Schaut mal, guckt mal. Ich mach mal kurz,
ich mach mal kurz den Keks weg und den Shelley weg und das Ding weg. So, schaut mal, ich bin,
glaube ich, der Einzige gerade auf der Welt, der noch zwei Raspberry Pi 4s rumliegen hat.
Danach noch im gescheiten Gehäuse. Ich habe noch zwei Picos und noch zwei Zero Ws, äh
Zero 2 Ws. Also ich bin da noch gut ausgestattet. Ansonsten ist es ja gerade schwierig, was
zu kriegen. Der muss irgendwie hier hinten in der Ecke, in die Ecke, sodass man sieht.
Sieht man den? Jawoll, sehr gut. Lenkt nur minimal ab. Aber irgendwie so, so kommt der
in die Ecke. Der muss irgendwie zugucken. Was liegt denn hier eigentlich alles für
einen Crap rum? Weg. So, hier guckt ihr jetzt. Ein Dreier habe ich auch noch irgendwo. Keine,
weil man nicht weiß, ob die flashbar sind, es sei denn du findest die User Bewertung,
die sagen, dass die explizit flashbar sind innerhalb der letzten paar Wochen noch. Prinzipiell
kann man da aktuell nichts empfehlen. Die hier habe ich mir auch schon gekauft vor, ähm,
man sieht doch auch schon ein bisschen staubig. Die habe ich mir auch schon gekauft vor fast
einem Jahr oder so. Und nicht verwirren lassen, weil da Hammer drauf steht. Das hat mit Hammer
so gut wie nichts zu tun. Das sind China-Leisten. Exakt die gleichen, die früher Gosund verkauft
und die dann sonst wer verkauft. Das ist alles China-OEM-Krempel, den die weiter verschachert
haben. Wenn die Sachen schon direkt mit TASMOTA verkaufen, ist nicht schlecht. Das war der
Vorteil, die war günstiger. Und es sind auch nur 3 Stecker. Ich finde 4 Stecker ist so,
4 Stecker und 4xUSB ist so der, wie sagt man so, der sweet spot. 3 Stecker sind ein bisschen
wenig, aber auf jeden Fall besser als China-Chinesen Cloud Crap. Die andere Alternative wäre irgendwelche
Lidl Zigbee Steckdosen leisten. Ja, ne November habe ich die. Woher weißt du, wann ich die
gekauft habe? Kein Quatsch. Storm of Nemesis, danke für den Sub. Wofür schlecht man Steckdosen
leisten? Dass man sowas hier machen kann. Dass man ein Webinterface hat, wo man dann
Sachen an und ausschalten kann. Ok, das ist jetzt mein Luftqualitätssensor, der war jetzt
ein schlechtes Beispiel. Der da vielleicht. Ja guckt, dann hat man zum Beispiel sowas
hier. Da hat man ein Webinterface, wo man die Sache an und ausschalten kann. Ich schalte
es jetzt nicht an und aus, weil ich nicht weiß, welche Steckdose das ist. Ich glaube,
das ist der Heizlüfter bzw. Ventilator im Bad vermute ich mal. TASMOTA Version uralt.
Nee, das ist die für 3D-Drucker glaube ich. Guck mal, TASMOTA Version uralt. IP-League,
oh nein. Leute, hackt mich nicht. Hackt mich nicht. Trotz IP-League. Seid nett, Chat.
Ich meine, ihr seid wahrscheinlich eh schon drin. Ja, die TASMOTA Version ist uralt,
so der Vorteil ist folgendes. Ich werde es jetzt nochmal kurz erzählen. Wer hat den gefragt?
Wo ist es denn? Hier, also es hat mehrere Vorteile. Normalerweise, guck mal hier, zum Beispiel
dieses Teil. Das ist ein bisschen mitgenommen, ich habe es hier gerade liegen, deswegen zeige
ich es jetzt nochmal. Zum Beispiel dieses Teil hier. Ja, das ist eine Steckdoseleiste
oder, warte mal, ich habe hier glaube ich noch ein besseres Beispiel, irgendwo rumfliegen.
Nee, egal. Also sprich, guck mal, das ist eine Steckdoseleiste mit, kann den Strom messen,
so in beschränkter Maße sagen wir mal, wenn China Zeug so genau ist, das nennt. Kann
es Strom messen, hast zwei Mal einen ausgenommen, hast zwei Stecker, leider hier kein USB. Warum
ist die so mitgenommen? Moment, ich mache mal kurz das Bild ein bisschen größer. Ach
so, ich muss ja noch das Licht anmachen, ich habe gar nicht das Licht an, wartet mal hier.
Ja, Chet, was sagt ihr? Mit Ringlight oder ohne Ringlight? Mit, oder? Mit ist auf jeden
Fall besser, dann erkennt man besser was. Ich denke mal, obwohl es aktuell halt auch
noch schön hell ist. So, also guckt mal, die sieht halt noch ein bisschen mitgenommen
aus hier, ihr seht es innen drin und ihr seht es auch hier noch. Vielleicht erinnert sich
der ein oder andere, guckt euch mal das hier an, vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder
andere, das war das Ding, was wir im Stream mal aufgebrochen haben mit dem Schraubendreher,
um an den Chip zu kommen, was gar nicht notwendig gewesen wäre, weil ich festgestellt habe,
hier unten drunter ist eine Schraube, um das Ganze aufzumachen. So, und der Vorteil, wenn
du so ein Ding hier hast, geflasht, oder wenn du so eine Steckdosenleiste hast, geflasht,
versus Stock mit China-Firmware ist, du brauchst keine China-Chinesen-App auf deinem Smartphone,
um das Ganze zu benutzen. Du kannst es einfacher in deine Heimautomatisierung integrieren,
weil das normale Standards unterstützt, das hat HTTP-Schnittstelle, das hat MQTT-Schnittstelle,
du kannst es generell über ein Webinterface steuern, was du normalerweise auch nicht machen
kannst. Und im Zweifelfall hast du sogar neue Funktionen, du kannst die Automatisierung
hinterlegen, wenn du es direkt da drauf machen willst. So, keine Ahnung, morgens um fünf
einen ausschalten, das Motor lässt sich ja auch beschränkt scripten. Also es ist eigentlich
nur von Vorteil im Vergleich zu... Achso, ja und das wichtigste habe ich ganz vergessen,
keine China-Chinesen-Firmware, die nach Hause funkt, falls sie das macht. Wahrscheinlich
macht sie das. Das beste was man machen kann ist, WLAN-Geräte zu flashen. Bisschen Asynchro
in die Kamera, guck mal hier. Na ja, passt halbwegs. Weiß nicht warum, vielleicht falscher
Codec eingestellt oder so. Weiß nicht. So und deswegen flasht man Steckdosen, weil man
ja kein Noob sein will, der den Chinesen Zeug heim schickt. Ne? So siehts aus. Deswegen
wird der Kram heute geflashed, wir müssen jetzt erstmal den Raspberry Pi Blatt machen.
Ich glaube wir nehmen den hier, weil, Achtung, da ist glaube ich unser Zappix drauf, an dem
wir irgendwann mal weiter bauen wollten. Und wenn ich den lösche, dann ist... Moment,
der Zappix ist da drauf. Ich könnte einfach, könnte einfach die SSD nehmen per USB und
dann die flashen. Wobei scheiß drauf, ich nehme den Raspberry Pi. Ich nehme den hier,
da ist eine SD-Karte drin und dann ist gut. So machen wir das. Die WLAN-Sachen sind gar
nicht schlecht. ZigBee-Sachen sind in der Regel, je nachdem was es ist, bisschen teurer, aber
nicht so krass wie Z-Wave. Und haben bei weitem nicht die Funktion, wie das geflashte WLAN-Gerät
mit Tasmota hat. Kann man machen. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel noch keine gute ZigBee-Steckdosenleiste
gefunden mit 4x USB und 4 Steckern. Oder am besten, wenn es an mir geht, dürfte es
theoretisch auch noch ein 5. Stecker sein. Hätte ich auch keine Schmerz mit. Platz wäre
ja gewesen, aber die Chinesen haben sich gedacht, ne, das wollten wir nicht. Ja, kann man auch
machen. Ja, NFC-Tax bzw. RFID-Tax sind extrem underrated. Sind das normale Werte für PC
mit zwei Monitoren? Chandler, ich klick von dir keine Links im Stream an, wenn ich nicht
weiß, was es ist. Warte mal. Sind das normale Werte für zwei Monitoren? Ok, das ist tatsächlich
country bait. Das ist ein richtig echter, normaler Link. Ok. Ähm, also. Sind das normale
Werte? Na gut, Energie total. Das ist ganz schön viel. Was? Das glaube ich nicht, dass
du... Das ist ein bisschen viel? Was hast du da dran hängen? Na gut, Moment. Today.
Na, knapp, knapp ein Ampere, ok, aber. Na, das passt doch. 193 Watt. Das kann doch sein,
je nachdem was du für Monitor hast, aber für normale Monitore ein bisschen viel, aber
ja, möglich, ja. Echt? Wirklich? Gar keine Absicht? Habe ich gar nicht geplant.
Hat sich einfach so ergeben. Patrick, du hast den Chat verwirrt. Guck mal. Hier bist du
hellgrün, da bist du dunkelgrün. Und es ist nicht, weil ich es irgendwie markiert hätte
oder so. Das ist, weil Twitch der Meinung war, hier musst du einmal hellgrün sein, einmal
dunkelgrün. Oder sagen wir normalgrün und hellgrün. Weiß, war wie gesagt überhaupt
nicht geplant. Bei mir auf dem zweiten Monitor sind die Farben auch normal, aber hier in
meinem Chat nicht. Was auch immer. Ja, also, wie gesagt, also ich habe diese Steckdosen,
ach nicht die da. Diese Steckdosenleiste war ungefähr in einem Jahr gekauft. Kann man
die noch finden bei Amazon? Ja. Dieses Teil hatte ich mir damals irgendwie im 5er Pack
oder so gekauft. Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob die noch flashbar sind. Die müsste noch
flashbar sein, weil ich habe aus diesem 5er Pack ja schon welche geflashed und die gingen.
Die Frage ist halt eher, ob das aktuell noch geht. Und da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen.
Sprich, wenn ihr das jetzt seht im Stream. Neueste. Wenn ihr das seht im Stream, nicht
unbedingt kaufen, einfach weil man sieht, dass es im Stream flashbar ist. Also ich weiß
nicht, ob die aktuell noch flashbar sind. Die sind schon fast ein Jahr alt. Alternative
Firm war flashbar, 30. Juni. Ja neun, die Steckdosenleiste bekommen gibt immer noch
mit Tuya Convert. Ja wir machen das jetzt auch mit Tuya Convert, weil ich habe keinen
Bock den Kram aufzuschrauben oder sowas in der Richtung. Und siehst du, das ist was,
was mich standardmäßig schon etwas, wie soll ich sagen, misstrauisch machen würde. Wenn
ich standardmäßig von überall auf der Welt meine Steckdosenleiste daheim schalten könnte.
Das bedeutet nämlich, die China-Chinesen haben quasi jetzt einen VPN bei euch ins Netzwerk
daheim. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das haben will. Und es ist kein richtiges VPN, aber naja,
also man könnte es als Zwischenhop verwenden. Also sprich, allein schon dadurch, dass man
mit der App die Steckdosenleiste schalten kann, ist schon mal irgendwas, irgendwas bisschen
schäpp. Ich mein, in Wirklichkeit wird es wahrscheinlich so gehen, hoffe ich mal, dass
die Steckdosenleiste sich zum Server verbindet und auf dem Server geschaltet wird bei den
China-Chinesen und dann die Steckdosenleiste das quasi subscribt hat über Websocket oder
sowas. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es sich wirklich verbindet auf eure Steckdosenleiste,
aber man weiß es nicht. Und die Möglichkeiten sind auf jeden Fall da und das ist ein weiterer
Grund, warum ich den Kram immer flashen würde. Du bist direkt im China-Botnetz, ja klar.
Tasmota möglich, ok. Das finde ich schon mal gut, dass so viele Leute schreiben. Anscheinend
kann man das Ding immer noch Tasmota flashen. Was ja auch so gut wie der einzige Verkaufsargument
ist. Ohne das Tasmota-Flashen würde ich den Kram im Leben nicht kaufen. Die Gose und App
exposed auch deine Public-IP. Ist wirklich so? Ja gut, bei dem China-Kram würde ich mich
echt nicht wundern. Achja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, dem China-Zeug nicht trauen. Ich zeige
euch mal was. Zeige euch mal was. So viel zu dem China-Kram Misstrauen. Seht ihr das
da? Verleuchtet euch da was auf. Außer dass es dreckig ist. So und die lag im Keller.
Man sieht das ja auch, die ist etwas mitgenommen. Die lag im Keller irgendwie zwei Jahre oder
so. Aber der Chat ist der Meinung, ist alles gut, die Steckdosenleiste war es nicht. Das
lag am Netzteil, was da drinnen gesteckt hat. Also wenn ich dem Chat vertraue, weiß
ich noch nicht so genau ob ich das machen sollte in dieser Frage. Wenn ich dem Chat traue,
dann ist mit der Steckdosenleiste alles in Ordnung und die geht immer noch. Das war
angeblich das Netzteil sagt der Chat. Und der Chat hat ja bekanntlichermaßen bei sowas
recht. So ich mache das Ding mal wieder weg. Eigentlich liegt das Ding schon auf dem Müll,
aber ich habe es jetzt rausgeholt wieder. Gut also ich würde sagen wir schnappen uns
mal den Raspberry Pi, wir machen mal kurz die Leiste hier weg, schnappen uns den Raspberry
Pi, ziehen die Micro SD Karte raus und flashen die mal. Und dann machen wir den ab und schließen
das Ding da an. Habe ich noch den aktuellen Raspberry Pi Image da drauf? Neues YouTube
wie der Twitch Chat fackelt meine Bude ab. Das müsste schon ein bisschen clickbaitier
sein dieser Titel. Ähm ich habe ein Problem. Ah ne habe ich nicht. Ich habe noch einen
gefunden guck mal. Gibot Cardreader mit der Krone. Normalerweise verwende ich einen anderen,
aber ich weiß nicht wo der gerade steckt. Der müsste auch hier liegen aber macht er
nicht. Machs gut Stripes. Orchester ruft. Pippo Jam. So flashen wir das Ding mal. Blllllllllllllllllll
Windows Sound. Alter warum steckt man USB? Prinzipiell falsch rum rein. Was ist es mit
dem USB? Nein nicht boot. Das soll an die VM durchgereicht werden. Nein. Äh nein. Ja.
Schon besser. Schon besser. Ja weil es USB C ist wahrscheinlich. Die Steckdose fängt
doch kein Feuer nur weil sie flasht. Die Steckdose fängt vielleicht Feuer weil China Chinesen
Zeug ist. Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich hatte bis jetzt noch nix was abgeraucht
ist. Wenn wir mal davon ausgehen dass die Steckdoseleiste in Ordnung ist weil der Chat das sagt und
wenn der Chat das sagt muss das ja so sein. Also mir fällt jetzt so spontan nix an was
mehr abgeraucht ist. So flashen wir den Karma. Also auf gehts. Raspberry Pi Imager. Nee
Pi Imager. Imager. Pi Imager. Meine Güte. Kurz gucken ob es Updates gibt. Schnell schnell
checken. Zeig mal her. Updates. Updates. Updates. Nein nicht ok. Hier auch nicht oder ich kann
grad nicht tippen. Es ging nicht ums flashen. Es ging halt darum dass ich dem China Zeug
nicht traue. Ja da hast du recht dem China Zeug kann man auch nicht wirklich trauen.
Es ist halt so. In dem Fall ist es halt ein deutscher Resale. Ja es ist aber immer noch
China Chinesen Zeug. Und da können noch so viele CE Zeichen und sonst was drauf sein.
Das interessiert die Chinesen ja nicht. Die drucken das halt drauf und gut ist. Ich hab
keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt was davon geprüft werden muss und was nicht. Aber wenn man bei
express kauft ist wahrscheinlich eh verloren. Wenn man bei Amazon.de kauft sollte das eigentlich
alles den Vorgaben entsprechen aber ob das jemand kontrolliert glaube ich nicht. Nee
das geht nicht mit Arduino und Co. Das ist es ja gerade. Wenn es mit Arduino und Co gehen
würde würde ich es mir mal angucken aber so verstehe ich den Sinn von Carbo nicht. Longboard
ist doch nicht mehr Hipster. Longboard war 2011 oder so Hipster wo Dana und Unge Longboard
Tour gemacht haben. Wie hieß der dritte Typ im Bunde damals? Ich hab das nie wirklich
ausführlich geguckt aber ich war noch zu dritt oder? War das Julien Bam? Nee oder? Cheng
das kann sein. Ich weiß zwar nicht wer Cheng ist aber doch was sah asiatisch aus der dabei
war. Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern. So also dann flashen wir den Raspberry Pi
jetzt mal. Imager. Gib ihm. So Choose OS. War das so? An den kann ich mich da gar nicht
dran erinnern. Wie gesagt ich hab das aber auch nie sonderlich ausführlich geguckt.
So Choose OS was wollen wir haben? Äh ehrlich gesagt ich nehm ein 32bit Leute wisst ihr
warum ich ein 32bit nehm ich bin mir nicht sicher ob Tuya Convert komplett mit 64bit
klarkommt. Sollte theoretisch aber es gibt ja keinen wirklichen Grund es zu machen mit
64bit in dem Fall. Also Raspberry Pi OS Lite 32bit 32G SSD Riot was? Ach Moment Moment
Edit Settings jaja. Enable SSH. Bestes Passwort Leute. 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 Best Practice Passwort
da kommt ihr nie drauf. Ok Riot. Yes. Gib ihm. Du benutzt seit 3 Jahren Arch als Main OS
einzig wahre. Die komischen Flex in Commands aus deiner History machen mir Angst. Welche
Flex denn? Was denn wo denn? Hier oder was? Das da? Oder das da? Wieso? Ganz normal.
Achso ihr Devil ist weil ich Git Repos habe. Das muss man machen. Ja aber Pacman kann man
sich glaube ich einen Y sparen. Ok die Micro SD Karte ist High Speed wie es aussieht. Warum
2x Y hat glaube ich keinen tieferen Sinn. Ich glaube du kannst sogar 3x Y machen und
es passiert nichts. Einfach 69xY. Mal mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert während er
gerade verified. Funktioniert guckt. 669xY. So muss das sein.
So wir können es removeen vom Card Reader. Da bin ich froh dass er mir das sagt. Alles
klar. So dann machen wir mal den Raspberry Pi an und installieren den ganzen Flashing
Rahmen drauf. So ich mach mal groß dass ihr was seht. Erste Mal Micro SD Karte. Wem passiert
das auch immer? Ich mach die eigentlich immer erst mal verkehrt. Nein. Also wir brauchen
auf jeden Fall einmal Netzwerk. Netzwerk und wir brauchen Strom für den Raspberry Pi.
Also das da. Hab ich da noch Platz für die Steckdosenleiste? Ich hoffe mal weil es wird
ein bisschen eng. So und er ist an. Er funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich nur mal kurz auf meinen Router
schauen. Was das Ding für eine IP kriegt. Router muss ich gucken. Router. Um die Cisco
Fans glücklich zu machen. So schauen wir mal. Was für Chinesen will Max flaschen?
Du meinst warum ich LS AERT mache oder so? Äh das kann ich dir sagen. Das ist all reverse
Time und human readable size. Das hat schon seinen Sinn. So Raspberry Pi 6049. SSH, Pi,
yes. Ich hoffe das ist der richtige. Uptime. Ne das ist nicht der richtige. 141 Tagen Uptime.
Das kann nicht der richtige sein. Außerdem ist das Netz komplett falsch. Wo ist er denn?
Wo ist er denn? Kein Raspberry Pi zu sehen. Switch ist an. Switch hat Link. Äh. So.
Ich glaube der ist. Ich glaube der hat ein Problem. Guck mal. Kackel. Ich glaube der
hat ein kleines Problem. Der leuchtet nicht mehr. Der geht immer an zwischendurch und
dann geht der wieder aus. Ist die SD Karte im Arsch? Normalerweise müsste der jetzt blinken
aber der blinkt nicht. Das ist definitiv irgendwas nicht richtig. Der müsste jetzt eigentlich
booten. Sollte ich vielleicht nochmal flashen? Ist das nicht geklappt? Zieh mal Strom ab
und wieder dran. Nein das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Strom ist ja dran. So Strom ab.
Strom dran. So. Dass er am Anfang grün ist ist ja normal. Und jetzt müsste er eigentlich
anfangen zu blinken gleich. Vielleicht muss man den Nintendo Trick machen Leute. Rausziehen
und mal pusten. Der blinkt nicht. Das ist äußerst verdächtig. Das ist äußerst verdächtig
dass der nicht blinkt. Moment hä? Was ist das jetzt? Nee der kann sich nicht entscheiden
was das ist. Ich guck mal ob man jetzt irgendwas DHCP-mäßiges sieht. Nö. Nix, nix DHCP-mäßiges.
Ich schließe da doch kein Monitor an. Das hat gefällig zu booten. Ok ne Leute ich glaube
mit der SD-Karte scheint irgendwas. Guck jetzt ist er wieder. Ich mein dass der das erste
mal Boot ein bisschen braucht ist klar. Der resized ja die SSD. Das ist normal. Aber
er holt sich keine DHCP-Adresse. Das stimmt schon mal. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö.
Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö.
Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö.
In dem Moment wo ich sag funktioniert's, na soll mir recht sein, so Uptime, eine Minute
das ist auf jeden fall der richtige.
So also, sudo, wir machen erstmal ein paar Updates, ja WiFi ist nicht an das ist mir
auch klar, WiFi brauchen wir gleich noch für was anderes.
Also Ziel ist es diese Steckdosenleiste zu flashen und danach die drei andere die ich
noch hab.
Upgrade.
Das smarte Wasserkocher, du meinst das Ding was wir uns mal angeguckt haben, das war total
unsinnig.
Im besten Fall mach ich irgendeine Steckdosenleiste die ich schalten kann an Wasserkocher, Wasserkocher.
Du hast es für 20 Euro im Sale bekommen, was ist das?
Ein smart Kettel, also ein smarter Wasserkocher für 43 Euro und was genau machst du damit
mit den Smart Funktionen dass sich das lohnt?
Und noch viel wichtiger, geht das auch ohne China-Chinesen-Firmware bzw. geht das ohne
China-Chinesen-App?
Geht das irgendwie über Bluetooth oder Zigbee oder sonst was oder wie pairt man das ganze?
Mit genau 80 Grad wäre ich vorsichtig bei dem China Zeug, bei China die nehmen es mit
den Werten nicht so genau, also 80 Grad könnte auch 85 oder 72 sein.
Ist Bluetooth, ok dann müssen wir mal gucken, dann müssen wir mal gucken, Github, Smart
Kettel, da gibt es doch bestimmt schon.
Smart Kettel BLE-Protokoll Reverse Engineering, aha, warum ist das archivet?
Der hüpft schon wieder, der ist umtriebig, muss man sagen, der ist echt umtriebig was
sowas angeht.
Was hat er denn da schon wieder gestrickt hier?
Guck mal, der unterstützt den Kram hier, was kann man damit jetzt machen?
MQ hat das Home Assistant Integration, Patrick den Chinesen traue ich alles zu, boah da könnte
ich mal eine Zahnbürste, das Ding brauche ich Leute, nächstes, das probiere ich mal
aus, das ist doch bestimmt ein Arduino-Sketch oder sowas, was er hier am Start hat oder?
Was, wait a minute, was ist das?
Ah, da brauchen wir eine Kiste mit einem Bluetooth-Stick oder so, es ist schon mal interessant,
weil, das Ding kann meine Waage und das Ding könnte auch meine Zahnbürste per MQTT auslesen.
Why not?
GitHub Oral-B Bluetooth, da gibt es doch bestimmt noch mehr, Toothbrushes Library, was nicht
alles gibt.
Get very useful and interesting information about your Toothbrush.
Toothbrush CLI, na endlich.
Toothbrush Oral-B AP, ja Leute, soweit sind wir, soweit sind wir schon, die Zahnbürste
per Bluetooth, so Update ist gelaufen, Instagram haben wir noch ein paar Standard-Dinger, die
wir bestimmt eh brauchen oder B-Top, wie die coolen Leute jetzt verwenden, Leute B-Top
gibt es beim Raspberry Pi nicht, Sachen gibt es, B-Top ist für die richtigen Hacker-Mans,
Leute.
Cool, Leute verwenden B-Top, H-Top, aber ganz ehrlich, ich verwende eh zu 90% immer
noch H-Top, gerade weil das auf den meisten Server-Kisten sogar mittlerweile drauf ist.
Gatschi-Top, Moment, also T-MAX geht, brauchen wir auf jeden Fall für irgendwelche Auslastung
oder so, aber ich glaube das passt schon.
So, und dann werden wir den Raspberry Pi gleich rebooten, achso, Moment, ich hab das allerwichtigste
Programm vergessen.
Der Chainlaw mag den Windows-Taskmanager, hat hier jeder seine Vorlieben, also mir ist
H-Top lieber, was wirklich cool ist beim Windows-Taskmanager, was ich unter Leidung auch gerne hätte,
ist GPU-Auslastung von Prozessen, das wäre echt nicht verkehrt.
KQS-Service, was hat das damit zu tun?
Was wollte ich jetzt machen, Leute, jetzt hab ich Chat gelesen, das hab ich vergessen,
ich wollte rebooten, nee, wollte ich machen.
Im Zweifelsfall rebooten, keine Ahnung, aber ein wichtiges Programm fehlt noch, stimmt,
stimmt, ihr habt recht, ASCII-Quarium fehlt noch, das muss drauf.
Ja, aber ich mein, integriert in irgendeinen standardmäßig vorhandenen Taskmanager, ja,
also wenn H-Top beispielsweise GPU-Sachen auch anzeigen könnte, das wäre schon cool.
Jep Hahn, auf Raspberry Pi Reboot, gib ihm.
Leute, morgen Frankfurt, Frankfurt, Iron Maiden Legacy of the Beast, morgen Abend 18 Uhr,
Bankbang, da, bin ich morgen Abend, im Waldstadion, wobei, das heißt ja nicht mehr Waldstadion,
das heißt ja jetzt Deutsche Bank Arena, da bin ich mal wirklich gespannt drauf, ob die
Alen Säge das noch hinkriegen, ich war vor zwei Jahren, nee, vor Corona war das, muss
dann schon vor drei Jahren oder vier Jahren gewesen sein, da war ich schon mal in Frankfurt,
das war in der Messerhalle, da war der Sound aber richtig kacke, du hast nix verstanden
und da bin ich mal morgen gespannt, Banger, sehr gut, geadded, Caelor hat zumindest guten
Emote-Geschmack, das steht glaube ich außer Frage gerade, schon viele gute Emotes vorgeschlagen,
was ist denn jetzt schon für ein Problem, warum, Raspberry Pi, warum kommst du nicht
drauf, was ist denn das, was hat der, was hat der für Probleme, was hat der für Schmerzen,
ich mein normalerweise, wenn ein Raspberry, der ist einfach komplett aus wieder, sag mal,
ok Leute, ich nehm mal ein anderes Netzteil, eigentlich reicht das Ding für den Raspberry
Pi, ich nehm mal das offizielle Raspberry Pi Netzteil, wenn ich das da irgendwie rauskrieg
so und wenn ich hier noch, jetzt hab ich halt keinen Platz mehr hier dafür, ich hab da
keinen Platz für, ich muss das hier nehmen, geht nicht anders, aber ganz davon abgesehen,
einfach zum starten reicht das, ich mein das ist kein 3 Ampere Netzteil, das ist nur
ein 2 Ampere Netzteil, aber das reicht normalerweise, dicke, auch für den 4er, ich mein das geht
ja nur ums booten und sonst nix, ok jetzt leuchtet er wieder, schauen wir mal, ja ich hab keinen
Platz hier, ich brauch die da, die Steckdose hier, die einzig freie Steckdose brauche ich
für die Steckdosenleiste, außen ist hier oben das Licht dran, deswegen ich könnt durchaus
mal ne Steckdosenleiste gebrauchen mit, der schaut wieder aus, fuck, ich glaub es reicht
doch nicht, was machen wir denn da jetzt, wenn es nicht bootet gescheit, ja dann muss
ich das doch rausziehen, man soll ich mal mit den USB Stecker hier unten vielleicht
probieren, geht das ja besser, schauen wir mal ob es jetzt geht, der Kram bootet einfach
nicht, da ist doch irgendwas im Arsch, ne jetzt bootet er, ok, er blinkt wie verrückt,
weiß nicht ob ihr das seht, hier müsste es, was ist denn das für ein, alter was ist denn
mit dem los, vielleicht hat er sich jetzt die SD Karte verabschiedet bzw. vielleicht
hat er jetzt Probleme gehabt weil er ein paar mal abgekackt ist beim booten, das verkraften
die nicht so gut, ok Leute ich warte jetzt mal, noch mal, ich warte jetzt noch mal kurz
und wenn es nicht geht, flash ich den nochmal neu, weiß nicht was das für ein Crap ist,
mal gucken was er jetzt macht, du bist wieder hellgrün ja, das switcht, ich mach das, ich
setze das im flashen, ich setze das in diesem Flash Menü, kennst du eine gute Smart Steckdose
mit der ich mal einen Stromverbraucher machen kann, naja die China Chinesen Dinger, die
ich hab, die meisten können das, also die hier kann das zum Beispiel auch, die Gosund
Steckdosenleiste, aber die Sache ist halt, du musst welche finden die noch flashbar sind,
ansonsten, ansonsten, nee, nee vergiss das, ich wollte dir ein Z-Wave Gerät vorschlagen,
das bringt dir aber nix, weil du hast ja kein Z-Wave, ok, das Ding ist im Arsch, der bootet
nicht, ich ziehe jetzt noch einmal den Stecker raus und mach den Stecker nochmal rein und
dann schauen wir ob es jetzt funktioniert, weil nicht flash ich nochmal neu, weil wir
haben nichts großartig gemacht, nee, der macht einfach gar nichts mehr, der hat einfach
keinen Bock zu booten, der ist RIP komplett, F, ok jetzt blinkt er mal kurz, jetzt blinkt
er, ok, der sieht aus als würde er booten gerade, WTF, was ist denn mit dem Teil los,
vielleicht ist die SD-Karte auch im Arsch, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, ich fasse
es jetzt nicht an, ich lasse es einfach so drauf, es funktioniert weiter, so, also SSH
drauf verbinden, 123456 Massive Passwort, meine Stream Vorschau ist gerade abgekackt,
nee, scheint noch alles zu funktionieren, es lebt, genau, ja also ich hab das allerwichtigste
vergessen zu installieren, Ascii-Quarium, falls das gibt, gibt's gar nicht, gibt, gibt
kein Ascii-Quarium, aber wenigstens C-Matrix hoffe ich mal, C-Matrix, C-Matrix installiert,
gut, gut, ah yes, jetzt haben wir schon mal, gut, das ist gerettet, wenigstens ein ordentliches
Programm drauf und auch ganz wichtig Hollywood, falls das gibt, Hollywood, Hollywood-Pommer
auch, Hollywood ist auch Pog, wenn ihr mal wieder, also wenn mal euer Chef ins Büro
kommt und ihr wollt wieder richtig oberkrasse Hacker-Man aussehen, dann müsst ihr Hollywood
starten, passt mal auf, ich zeig euch das gleich mal, auf dem Raspberry Pi zu erzählen
ist reichlich sinnlos, das würde ich eher lokal installieren, aber ok, aber wenn wir
schon dabei sind, unsinnige Sachen zu interessieren, braucht es dann für Pakete vieles, weil es
vieles unter der Haube aufruft, guck mal wie lahm die SSD ist, nicht die SD, die Micro-SD,
Pearl alles drauf, Python, Pearl, Ruby, Beemon, das für die Bandbreite, so passt mal auf Hollywood,
richtiger Hacker-Man Kram, yes, so, also wenn ihr mal wirklich wie im Film aussehen wollt,
dann einfach Hollywood starten, heißt nicht umsonst so, no more secrets, das habe ich
glaube ich auch auf dem Host drauf, das habe ich auch drauf, no more secrets, ne habe ich
nicht installiert, so, so muss das sein, so jetzt haben wir genug uns wie die krassen
Hacker-Mans gefühlt, jetzt brechen wir mal ab, alles klar, so jetzt machen wir was sinnvolles,
das was wir nämlich eigentlich machen wollten, nehme ich den ganzen Krempel flaschen, also
brauchen wir dieses Tulia, ne nicht vom Hüpfer, das da, Tulia Convert, wenn ich das richtig
in Erinnerung habe, muss man das erstmal klonen, shit, clone, ah ich weiß was ich vergessen
habe, Bash Completions habe ich vergessen, falls es nicht schon drauf ist, ist schon drauf,
cool, git clone, Tulia Convert, so und dann müssen wir uns die Anleitung angucken wie
das funktioniert, install prerequisites, second device, oh da brauche ich gleich, muss ich
gleich rüber nochmal ein iPad holen, sonst funktioniert es nämlich nicht, so Tulia Convert,
install prerequisites.sh, so während das installiert, Leute ich hole mal kurz mein iPad, er muss,
als man die Geräte flaschen kann, muss man ein zweites Gerät im Netzwerk hängen, also
ich bin back, so, was wir machen, hier steht doch im Titel, ich flasche meine restlichen
China Chinesen Steckdosen Reserven die ich habe, danach gibt es nichts mehr, doch, doch
klar, Bash Completions unter root an, so, da haben wir es, warum ist da ein Dockerfile
drin, das brauchen wir nicht, wir installieren jetzt alles auf dem Raspberry Pi, also start
flash, erstmal kurz überlegen, mache ich das jetzt gerade richtig, start flash, also
da steht ja auch da, achso, Moment, bevor ich flasche sollte ich vielleicht mal das
Ding auspacken und anschließen, also das Teil flaschen wir jetzt von Hammer, aber es ist
nicht wirklich von Hammer, es ist ein ganz normaler China Chinesen Resale Ding, erstmal
aufgerissen, elegantes auspacken, so, da ist es, exellent, warum gibt es danach nichts
mehr, weil die meisten nicht mehr flashbar sind, die man heute kaufen kann, oder komplett
einen anderen Chip drin haben, der gar nicht mehr Tasmota flashbar ist, ich meine Tasmota
ist eine ESP-6860 ESP-32 Firmware, das heißt das läuft auf einem anderen Chip auch nicht,
so, also das Ding werden wir jetzt flashen, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher wie es
geht, wie man das Ding in den Flash Modus versetzt, aber ich glaube einfach anschließen reicht,
also, was ich bei diesen Steckdosenleisten ganz cool finde ist folgendes, man hat vier
normale Steckdosen, die man alle getrennt schalten kann, das ist schon mal nice, nicht
wie diese billige Steckdosen, die es teilweise gibt, wo du alles nur auf einmal schalten kannst,
der Schalter hier vorne kann mit Tasmota beliebig umprogrammiert werden, Tasmota kann ja bis
zu, frag mich nicht, 25 verschiedene Funktionen für so Schalter, du kannst den Schalter programmieren
auf Schalten einer der Liste, du kannst sagen Doppelklick schaltet, also einfacher Klick
schaltet ein, Doppelklick schaltet zwei, Dreifachklick schaltet drei, Vierfachklick
schaltet vier, habe ich noch nie gemacht, geht aber glaube ich, und dann kannst du USB
schalten, allerdings USB kannst du nicht einfach schalten, USB kannst du nur alle vier auf
einmal anmachen oder aus, was aber in der Regel reicht, also jeder von den 230 Volt Steckdosen
kannst du einzeln schalten, aber USB kannst du alle vier nur auf einmal schalten, das
wäre natürlich besonders hyper geil, wenn das irgendwie gehen würde, mit die hier auch
noch einzeln anstrengen, aber ja, wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben, so, ob das
jetzt geht mit dem Knopf, ist mir eigentlich egal, also ich weiß es geht mit dem Knopf,
man kann das einstellen, ist mir aber eigentlich egal, weil ich schalte das Ding eh nur über
meine Home Automation, wo ich ein bisschen unschlüssig bin, ist was das da ist, das
hat, guck mal, das hat da einen Knopf, den kann man drücken, und ich habe keine Ahnung,
vielleicht ist das Wasser ablaufen oder so, keine Ahnung was das ist, eine Sicherung ist
es auf jeden Fall eher nicht, so, dann wollen wir mal probieren das zu flashen, also von
der Idee her sollte das jetzt folgendermaßen funktionieren, wir starten das Flaschen jetzt
hier auf dem Raspberry Pi, schalten das Ding in den Flash Modus, dann sollte das hier
blinken, unterschiedlich, und dann sollten wir auf dem Raspberry Pi sehen, ob er flasht
oder nicht, das Ding ist, naja, was heißt, übelst groß, ja, übermäßig groß ist das
nicht, man hier oben brauchst du alles, da unten brauchst du alles, hier könntest du
fly eine extra Steckdose hin machen, aber ansonsten, ich meine, guck, du hast doch die
größten Vergleich zum Raspberry Pi, so riesengroß ist das Ding, nett, was ist denn das, 30
Zentimeter oder so, also irgendwie so, das ist nicht größer als normale Steckdosenleisten
auch, so, mal so machen, dass man das parallel zugucken kann, also, do you wish to terminate
den S-Mask, yes, yes, mach, starting access point, so, jetzt muss ich mich mit meinem
Tablet, jetzt muss ich mich mit meinem Tablet connecten, das mach ich jetzt, da lass ich
euch nicht zugucken, connect any other device, mach ich jetzt, we trust flash, so, ich bin
mit meinem Tablet connected, und jetzt, put your IOT device, ja, machen wir, also, einfach
anschließen und hoffen, dass es flasht, noch machts nix, achso, press enter, ich presse
mal enter, ich muss es wahrscheinlich lang gedrückt halten, ich halte mal lang gedrückt,
jetzt blinkt es schnell, seht ihr das, jetzt blinkt es schnell, ich weiß nicht, ob man
das erkennt, jetzt blinkt es schnell, und jetzt sollte es eigentlich, ne, ne, das hat
nicht funktioniert, ok Leute, nochmal von vorne, raus machen, äh, der ist nicht im
flash Modus, ok, nochmal länger gedrückt halten, jetzt blinkt es schnell, ah, ne, was,
yes, yes, hat sich mein Tablet wieder ausgelockt, ah, jetzt hat es sich resettet, ok, jetzt
hat es sich resettet, Mist, das hat nicht funktioniert, ich will abbrechen, please abbrechen, yes, yes,
was jetzt, das funktioniert nicht,
das funktioniert nicht, ok, ich erinnere mich, ich hatte es letztes mal auch Probleme mit
den Dinger, die zu flashen, ich hatte es letztes mal auch Probleme, das zu flashen, das muss
ich auch ein paarmal machen, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, was das Problem war, ja,
weil da auf Amazon was steht, heißt es nicht, dass jede Steckdosenleiste funktioniert, funktioniert
nicht, normalerweise sollte der, ich reboote das Ding jetzt nochmal, ich reboote den Raspberry
Pi nochmal, ich hoffe, dass der jetzt rebooted und mache die Leiste nochmal raus und wir
schauen mal kurz, wie man das Ding, wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal kurz bei, ähm, dieser,
das Motor Template Seite, Motor Template, Supported Devices, Kogeek, das da ist das im Original,
glaube, na dazu steht nichts da, haben die vielleicht sinnvolle Sachen auf Amazon stehen,
das Motor, was ist das für eine Antwort, jemand probiert, ob sich aktuell noch das
Motor flashen lässt, die ist richtig gut, hält lange warm, alles klar, so pepega diese
Amazon Rezession teilweise, also nicht Rezession, User, User, wie nennt sich das, FAQ Sachen,
das Motor, ok, der hat aufgeschraubt,
ok, der hat aufgeschraubt, das ist schonmal eher doof,
das ist eher doof, sag mal, ein Raspberry Pi startet schon wieder nicht, was ist denn
das, Alter, dieses Crap Teil, ich fass es nicht, warum buggt das so rum, was soll das
hier, ich glaube, die SD hat irgendeinen Schaden, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal, der war
schon im Flash Modus, hast ja auch gesehen, dann hat es hier umgeschaltet, aber nicht
mal gebootet, also nicht mehr richtig gebootet danach, ey, der Raspberry Pi ist mega im Arsch,
also nicht nur, dass aus irgendwelchen unsinnigen Gründen brutales heiß wird, obwohl nichts
ist, aber jetzt bootet er, ok, die Logik verstehe ich echt nicht, jetzt bootet er anscheinend,
soll mir recht sein, was war man da jetzt, also ich fürchte, die werden wir nicht geflasht
kriegen, OTA, die letzte konnte man lustigerweise OTA noch flaschen, Raspberry Pi ist wieder
da, also anscheinend ist nicht alles flashbar per OTA, selbst letztes Jahr nicht, ok, das
start Flash, yes, yes, alles klar, so Tablet verbinden, ja connect any device, put your
IOT device in auto config, LED will blink fast, jaja, das habe ich schon gemacht, das
bringt nichts beim Restart, beim Restart geht es da nicht weiter, das ist an, ich weiß nicht
ob ihr das seht, ich weiß nicht ob man das sieht, das ist grün, das ist grün, ne das
grüne Licht erkennt man nicht genau, zumindest wenn ich das jetzt eine Weile gedrückt halte,
dann blinkt das schnell, man sieht das, man sieht das echt nicht, das ist ziemlich, ziemlicher
Müll, hier guckt mal, ne man sieht nicht das es blinkt, aber Leute glaubt mir es blinkt,
das grün erkennt man nicht richtig, es blinkt schnell, also der ist auf jeden Fall im Flash
Modus und das merke ich auch, weil jetzt restartet der und dann sagt er auch auto config is complete,
was allerdings dazu führt, dass er sich nur rebootet und es da nicht weiter geht, das
ist ziemlich blöd, man kann das Ding wahrscheinlich nicht flashen per OTA, ich habe die alle zeitgleich
gekauft, eine ließ sich flashen und die andere die ich im Schrank habe habe ich bis jetzt
nicht ausprobiert, aber anscheinend lässt er sich nicht flashen, ich höre es auch es
rebootet und die Relays gehen an und aus und dann geht er in normalen Modus, also das sollte
so nicht funktionieren, was genau bringt es eine Steckdosenleiste zu flashen, zum Beispiel
dass du keine Smartphone App vom China Hersteller mehr brauchst oder die Chinesen sich auf deine
Steckdosenleiste einloggen können und es hat auch weitere praktische Vorteile, du kannst
es über ein Webinterface steuern anstatt mit der App, du kannst es per MQTT in dein Smart
Home integrieren und allgemein lässt sich das viel besser steuern und ansprechen, Moment
es hat was gemacht, hat es funktioniert, es geht einfach, man muss es einfach 10 mal probieren
und dann gehts, easy, easy, flash Tazmota, yes, manchmal hilft es alles zu rebooten,
alles zu rebooten und dann nochmal zu probieren und dann, do you want to flash another device,
gerade nicht, no, gut, jetzt muss ich das Tazmota verbinden, das zeige ich euch nicht,
weil dann würde ich mein WLAN Passwort leaken und das habe ich nicht vor, ich möchte mein
WLAN Passwort nicht leaken, ich hoffe ihr versteht mich ja, Chat, please no disabo, jetzt muss
ich mein Passwort eingeben, das ist ewig lang, das enthält Kekkel, das kann ich euch verraten,
ja aber nicht, Kekkel und Koggers, aber anders geschrieben,
so ich hoffe ich habe mich nicht vertippt, safe, jetzt gucke ich in meinen Router, ob
ich die Tazmota Sachen sehe, IP DHCP Server, leases, aha, ich habe da 2 Sachen die in Frage
kommen aber ich weiß nicht welche es ist, das da vielleicht, das da vielleicht, postchamp,
also von der Adresse könnte es das durchaus sein, aber es antwortet nicht, ah easy, das
ist das richtige, so gerade mein DHCP richtig benennen, passt, so also, gut so, Tazmota ist
halt uralt, das müssen wir jetzt erstmal upgraden, aber das wichtigste, ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob ich auf die Konsole gehen kann, doch ich kann auf die Konsole gehen, ist nicht Schlimmes,
weil, wobei keine Ahnung, bin mir nicht sicher, nee ich habe extra WLAN gemacht, nur für
den Stream, dann passiert nichts, schlimmste was ich leaken kann ist MAC Adresse vom Device
und sowas und das ist egal, muss NTP Server setzen, NTP Server 1 1 2 2 1 6 8 60.1, weil
ansonsten wenn, Leute falls jemand Probleme von euch hat, so mal als Tipp, wenn euer Tazmota
richtig langsam reagiert, so wie meins jetzt, dann müsst ihr NTP Server setzen, guckt euch
das mal an, wenn ihr nämlich kein NTP Server setzt, ich zeige ich dir gleich Major Laser,
ich kann alles einzeln steuern, legen wir schon mal so hin, dass man es gleich sieht,
irgendwie so, kann man mal kurz schauen, dass man es vielleicht ein bisschen, dass man das
ordentlich sieht, aber erstmal muss mein Tazmota aufgehen, was es gerade nicht macht, solange
kein NTP gesetzt ist, ist es richtig langsam, man muss NTP Server setzen, also wenn ihr auch
das Problem habt, dass euer Tazmota mega langsam ist, dann NTP Server setzen, easy, das kann
jetzt mal 1-2 Minuten dauern bis es aufgeht, alternativ Stecker raus, Stecker rein, wieso
braucht der NTP, das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung, Console, guck hier falsche Zeit, falsche
Zeit, ich hoffe ich habe jetzt kein WLAN Passwort geleakt, sieht nicht so aus, also NTP Server,
ein bisschen größer, dass ihr was seht, NTP Server setzen, NTP Server 1, NTP Server 2,
NTP Server 3, ihr seht schon es lag drum, so und wenn jetzt der NTP Server gesetzt ist,
Tazmota System Time, ich weiß nicht mal wieder, Tazmota Time, Tazmota Time, wie konnte man
sich das nochmal anzeigen lassen, Show System Time, hast du Public NTPs geblockt, ja genau,
genau das will ich haben, zeigt mir die Zeit an, alles klar NTP Server und jetzt haben
wir 19.22.2022, 25.07., ja, vielleicht müsst ihr auch noch save machen, aber ne, warte
mal, Tazmota save, aber normalerweise müsst ihr das nicht machen, weil ihr jede Sekunde
automatisch, automatisch speichert die Fall mäßig, weiß gar nicht was der richtige Befehl
zum speichern ist ehrlich gesagt gerade, na egal, müsst ihr nicht machen, so, jetzt Restart
und dann soll es zumindest schneller sein, auch nach dem Reboot jetzt, guck das ist sind
wieder da, Console, jetzt gehts, jetzt gehts sofort wieder, guck, jetzt gehts, jetzt gehts
direkt, ja, direkt, ohne was, so, jetzt hat er nämlich auch gleich den ganzen Krempel,
ja wunderbar, so und jetzt gehen wir in Configuration, gute Frage, das da, glaub ich, noch mal schauen,
jetzt muss uns die richtige Gerätekonfig heraussuchen, ich probiers mal mit der hier, weil das die
baugleiche Steckdosenleiste ist, testen wir mal ob das funktioniert, wir sollten dem Ding
noch einen gescheiten Namen geben, nämlich, die heißt jetzt einfach Hammer, Hammer, äh,
keine Ahnung, was sagen die dann offiziell wie das Ding heißt, was, was, was sagen die,
die Hammer Leute denn, Hammer Power Strip, na geil, da weiß man Bescheid, Freifall, ich
mach einfach Hammer, Vierer, Device Name, ja das ist ziemlich egal, aber ich nenns trotzdem
mal, ähm, kommt wahrscheinlich in Keller, sodass ich noch weiß wie es heißt, so Restarten
und jetzt sollten wir vier Stecker sehen, ich bin mir nicht sicher ob mal, ob ihr das
hört, aber ihr sollte das, ihr sollte das zumindest sehen, seht ihr das, ok, die Anzeige
ist richtig pepega, ihr seht das wahrscheinlich nicht, ich mach mal kurz das Licht aus, ich
mach kurz, ich mach kurz mein Ringlight aus, weil sonst erkennt ihr einfach gar nix, naja,
gut erkennen ist was anderes, aber ihr müsstet es hier oben rechts sehen, guckt mal, seht
ihr das, ja so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen sieht man das, gell, guckt, jetzt ist an,
ja besser, besser gehts grad nicht, so nächster an, da musst du aber ganz genau hingucken
dass du das erkennst, so und jetzt alles an inklusive USB, guckt hier oben, also ich seh
es gut, aber in der Kamera erkennt man es überhaupt nicht gescheit, ja hier oben, hier oben sieht
man jetzt ein bisschen, also man kann jetzt tatsächlich alles einzeln, alles einzeln
schalten und der Knopf funktioniert auch, der Knopf schaltet aktuell nur die erste
Steckdose, aber das juckt mich nicht, man könnte jetzt verschiedene Funktionen vergeben
für den Knopf, da müssen wir mal nachgucken, also man kann hinter das Motor so Sachen machen
wie Button, Button ummappen, das ist aber, das ist ein bisschen Fivehead, ja man sieht
es nicht schlecht, aber zumindest das der Power Knopf angeht, sieht wahrscheinlich
jeder, guckt jetzt der Power Knopf aus, wenn man sich ein bisschen einfacher machen will,
jetzt machen wir erstmal ein Tasmota Update, Tasmota OTA Update, Tasmota Bin, ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob wir Bin oder Minimal brauchen, gucken wir mal, Firmware Upgrade,
das geht nicht, Internet Zugang ist komplett geblockt, keine Chance, Download, wir machen
mal ein normales Update, es kann sein, ist es schon standardmäßig so was du sagst, ich
dachte das muss man alles von Hand vergeben, von Hand machen, so, jetzt geht erste an,
Doppelklick, nö, ach doch tatsächlich, dann ist es standardmäßig schon so wie ich sage,
guck mal, Tripleklick, geht die dritte gleich aus, eins, zwei, drei, dritte aus, zwei,
drei, vier, vierte an, dann ist das sogar standardmäßig schon so wie ich gesagt hab,
ja, auch wenn man es nicht richtig erkennt, aber was will ich machen, ja und schaut mal,
man sieht das ja auch im Menü, guck mal, wenn ich hier drücke, erkennt er sofort eins
ist an und aus, so aber jetzt machen wir erstmal Update, also wenn ihr Tasmota verwendet kann
es sein, dass ihr Probleme beim Update bekommt, nämlich je nachdem, wie viel Speicher euer
Gerät hat, probieren wir das mal aus, also standardmäßig würde ich immer probieren
auf die volle Tasmota Version zu upgraden, wenn es nicht funktioniert, ich zeige euch
mal was man macht, wenn es nicht funktioniert, wenn das nicht funktioniert und wenn er sagt,
zu wenig Speicher, dann müsst ihr einen Zwischenschritt machen, dann müsst ihr erst auf die Minimal
Version updaten und dann auf die größere, also machen wir das mal, Tasmota Minimal Upgrade,
also wenn die Geräte zu wenig Speicher haben, dann hat er nicht genug Platz, die aktuelle
Firmware plus die neue Firmware in Flash zu kriegen und da musst du erst noch eine kleinere
Firmware Flashen, die im Prinzip nichts kann, außer Updates machen und dann kannst du drüber
Flashen, kommt Minimal Firmware und jetzt sag mal nochmal Upgrade und jetzt kann man
die standardmäßig, die fette Tasmota hochladen, fette Tasmota Firmware hochladen, so und jetzt
wenn er Restart hat, sag mal auch schon 1202, was schonmal deutlich besser ist, weil das
was aktuell ist es und jetzt sollte er irgendwann Restartet haben, in der Hoffnung, dass er
die NTP Settings nicht vergessen hat, was durchaus sein kann, weil ich glaube ein Tasmota
9 auf 12 Upgrade, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob das supported ist, überhaupt in einem
Rutsch, schauen wir mal, doch hat alles funktioniert, so wunderbar, so und jetzt kann man die Dinger
noch ein bisschen ordentlich benennen, dass man später im Webinterfell in seiner Heimautomatisierung
auch checkt, was was ist, ich glaube das ist unter Template, oh ne wie benennt man die Knöppe,
ConfigModule, Template hier, Moment wie benennt man Tasmota nochmal die Knöppe, hätte eigentlich
gedacht hier drüber, Friendly Name 1-4, ja aber wo ist das, wo war denn das nochmal,
da, ach hier, genau hier, genau und die kann man jetzt benennen, also ich persönlich benenne
die Dinger endgültig eigentlich in meiner Heimautomatisierung, also in meinem Home Assistant
steht dann zum Beispiel drin, Keller Raspberry Pi, das würde ich hier nicht unbedingt, unbedingt
so nennen, weil vielleicht steckt ihr die Steckdosenleiste mal woanders hin, ich würde
sie aber auch nicht Tasmota 1-2-3-4 nennen, weil ihr habt am Ende sonst ganz ganz viele
Geräte die Tasmota 1-2-3-4 heißen, also irgendwie nen gewissen Identifier für die Steckdosenleiste
ist schon nicht verkehrt, wenn die Dinger offensichtlich irgendeine Nummer oder so drauf
stehen haben, dann kann man das machen, also das Ding hat hinten als Nummer, ja hier guckt
mal, das ist natürlich optimal, wenn da irgendeine Seriennummer oder sowas drauf steht, dann
kann man die verwenden, ja also zum Beispiel steht hier was 0017674 drauf, dann erfindet
man die Leiste im Zweifelsfall auch wieder, aber wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben,
man könnte natürlich auch den Labelchamp nehmen, wenn ich den mal irgendwann fertig
programmiert hätte und ein Label drucken, nachdem ich den Labelchamp aber noch nicht
fertig programmiert habe, werden wir jetzt was anderes machen, das habe ich tatsächlich
bei den Geräten die ich im Haus verteilt habe, öfters schon gemacht, allerdings nicht
bei allen, aber bei allen von denen ich mir dachte ich muss die mal wieder finden.
Ja und zwar, dass man sowas hier nimmt, das ist ein Labelprinter und da zum Beispiel jetzt
drauf schreibt, wir schreiben jetzt auf den Labelprinter auf cute, chat, chat und dann
drucken wir das aus, dann kommt hier neben irgendwie so ein Ding raus, 40 Euro das Ding,
das da, ja das ist ein ganz billiger, so und dann kommt dann so ein Label raus, das ist
relativ relativ beständig und das ist auch selbst klebend, man muss bloß das Papier
da hinten abmachen und das ist jetzt der Inventartack, wie man es will, für diese Steckdoseleiste
und dann kann man hingehen und sagen aha das hier ist nicht Hammer, sondern das ist Hammer
cute chat, so und dann kann man die Dinger durch benennen, was für ein Gerät dann am
Ende drauf kommt, das würde ich hier nicht machen, den würde ich nicht viel, sondern
USB nennen, save und jetzt hat man auch ordentliche, ordentliche Benahmung, hier steht immer noch
1, 2, 3 dran, ich bin mir relativ sicher, man kann diese Knöppe hier auch umbenennen,
das weiß ich auch nicht warum es keine Querztastatur ist, wahrscheinlich weil das nicht passen
würde von der Höhe, nach Querz hat ihr normalerweise nur 3 Reihen und die hier hat 5 Reihen, keine
Ahnung, zumindest wenn ihr das jetzt in eure Heimautomatisierung einbindet, dann ist es
ordentlich benannt, ich weiß nicht wie man diesen Scheiß hier setzt, es geht, ich weiß
dass es geht, ja, pass motor, button name, web button, der Chat weiß Bescheid, web button
ja, schauen wir mal, etwas groß ja, aber es funktioniert, gut, alternativ, ja das hier
zu benennen ist natürlich relativ, relativ sinnlos, also ich würde es ehrlich gesagt
einfach so lassen wie es standardmäßig ist, was dieser Analogsensor ist, habe ich übrigens
keine Ahnung, der taucht bei jedem dieser Leisten auf, hat keinen sinnvollen Wert und
macht nichts was irgendwie sinnvoll wäre, also keine Ahnung, für was dieser Analogsensor
ist, so und jetzt haben wir eine Steckdoseleiste, die man schalten kann, das hier sollte USB
sein, yep, yep, Hahn und das passt, eigentlich alles gut, so soll es sein, so, nachdem ich
den Kram jetzt nicht neu machen will, copy paste ich mir das mal, das soll ich es nicht
Hammer Vierer nennen, Hammer Vierer ist irgendwie doof, Hammer Cute Chat soll das heißen, weil
das ist ja der Typ im Endeffekt, Hammer, was ist jetzt Hammer Vierer, ist mir doch wurscht,
so, ich weiß gar nicht ob man das Motorgescheit-Config exportieren kann oder so, ah Backup-Config
kann man machen, aber dann ist es doppelt, zumindest, jetzt könnte man die nächste Steckdoseleiste
nehmen und Flashen, ich würde sagen eine machen wir noch Chat, weil ich glaube bei
vier Stück wollte er mir jetzt nicht zugucken, so spannend ist das nicht, oder doch, tja
gibt es sonst noch irgendwas was ich euch zeigen kann, was man einstellen kann, also
wie gesagt, man kann mit Tasmota schon jede Menge Zeug machen, also ihr könnt beispielsweise
hier An-Aus-Schalt-Schedules angeben und sowas, Konfig Timer, also ihr könnt hier
beispielsweise einstellen wann das automatisch angehen soll, wann das automatisch ausgehen
soll, aber ganz im Ernst, man kann das zwar machen in Tasmota, ich würde es aber über
meine Heim-Automatisierung machen und nicht da drüber, kommt mal jetzt, jetzt wisst ihr
auch wozu das Ding Zeitzone und NTP braucht, dass es Sunrise und Sunset und so weiß, weil
das kriegst du nicht hin ohne Infos über Timezones und sowas, ja also ehrlich gesagt
ich habe Timers, Timers in Tasmota noch nie verwendet, ich würde es über meine Heim-Automatisierung
machen, Tasmota ist mega komplex, Tasmota hat sogar eine eigene Scripting Language wo
du das dann automatisieren kannst, aber naja, das kannst du super easy in Home Assistant
integrieren, das kann ich jetzt gerade nicht zeigen, weil ich das im WLAN hängen habe
und ich nur hier in den Heim-Home Assistant bei mir im Internet hochfahren könnte, das
ist super easy zu integrieren, du musst eigentlich ja so gut wie nichts machen, du installierst
die Tasmota Integration und dann gehst du in die Konsole und sagst ein Kommando und
dann, also du machst die MQTT Settings, die stellst du ein von deinem MQTT Broker, die
vom Home Assistant und dann machst du ein Kommando in der Konsole und er meldet sich
am Home Assistant an mit allem was er für Geräte hat, also mit dem Fall fünf Switches.
Ja Leute, den Label-Champ, den müssten wir echt fertig machen.
Ja, so was kann man machen, ja, also wie gesagt, Tasmota, Tasmota hat eine eigene Scripting
Language.
Ja, ach ist das nur auf dem ESP32, ne da könntest du darauf nicht machen.
Ahja, na das ist sie, wusste ich gar nicht, aber wie gesagt würde ich eh nicht darüber
machen, ich würde das über meine Smart Home Lösung machen und nicht hier irgendwie auf
der Steckdosenleiste großartig Logik laufen lassen, ich mein, wir reden hier allen Ernstes
über Customs-Scripter auf Steckdosenleisten, wir müssen es mal nicht übertreiben.
Ja, ich habe Label-Champ auch nicht weiter gemacht.
Was fertiges kenne ich auch nicht, vielleicht irgendwelche ZigBee-Dinger, also falls du
Z-Wave hast, Z-Wave kann ich dir eine empfehlen, die das kann, aber ZigBee weiß ich nicht
und vielleicht ein Shelly, vielleicht die Shelly-Kiste, also wenn du was fix und fertiges
suchst, musst du mal gucken, ob das Shelly, ob das Shelly Smart Plug das kann, die sind
fix und fertig, die musst du nicht flashen.
Kann das Shelly Smart Plug das, Power Measure, Power Metering, ja, ja, also wenn du ein bisschen
mehr ausgeben willst als die China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleiste, dann kannst du hier ein Shelly Smart, Shelly
Plug S kaufen, die kommen fix und fertig mit ziemlich guter Firmware, die muss man nicht
flashen und die kannst du flashen, weil es halt nicht abgeschottet ist irgendwie, also
die Shelly-Dinger sind für alle, die nicht selbst flashen wollen, natürlich immer eine
sinnvolle Alternative.
Guck mal, was kostet der Kram aktuell auf Amazon, ja, ihrer Packung, ja du kannst easy
das Motor flashen drauf, aber die Standard-Firmware ist auch okay, ja, die Standard-Firmware braucht
keine Cloud, also nicht zwingend und kann MQTT und HTTP und sowas, ja, also so sieht
es aus, gut, dann würde ich sagen, FUNST und NEXT, NEXT, auf geht's, raus mit dir und
in die Ecke gefäffert, ich hab da ein Kissen liegen, also ich hab die nicht wirklich in
die Ecke gefäffert, also die lebt noch, die ist nicht kaputt, ich hol mal die nächste
Steckdosenleiste
und jetzt mach ich mal wieder das Licht an, weil, so sieht man einfach besser, so, also
dann packen, den machen wir mal weg, dann packen wir mal aus, alter was ist, wie ist es denn
überhaupt gedacht, Moment, ich muss es mal kurz analysieren, wie ist es gedacht aufzumachen,
da ist ja Plastik, ich müsste das gar nicht aufreißen, ich könnte das einfach am Plastik
aufmachen, guckt mal, easy, ist ja für Loops, das geht dann einfach auf, guckt euch das
mal an, was soll denn das, ohne kaputt zu reißen geht das dann auf, LUL, LUL HD, ok,
so gleich nochmal von vorne, Start, nee Moment, langsam, langsam, so, anstöpseln und in Flashing
Modus packen, so, Plinkt ist im Flashing Modus, Start, Flash, so jetzt mit dem Tablet connecten,
Tablet is connected, put your IOT device things, press enter, müsste es eigentlich klicken,
es hat geklickt, ok, ok, es hat geklickt, so hoffen wir mal, dass es jetzt einfach funktioniert
wenn ich es nicht wieder 5 mal neu machen muss wie beim letzten Mal, ok, eins hab ich
schon gemerkt, wenn das dieses config package senden eine Weile dauert, dann klappt das
meistens, das
dauert aber schon ganz schön lang jetzt, warum fischst du eine Steckdosenleiste, so, ja hat
funktioniert wunderbar, easy, warum fischst du eine Steckdosenleiste, dass ich sie ohne
China Chinesen Cloud betreiben kann, ist eines der Punkte und dass ich es besser in
mein Smart Home integrieren kann ist ein weiterer Punkt, so also was wir haben, Flash Tasmota,
yes, do you want to Flash Tasmota, yes, billig, so und dann muss ich den ganzen Müll nochmal
übers Tablet an WLAN Passwörtern eingeben wieder, no, gut, hat funktioniert mit dem Flaschen,
jetzt müssen wir Tasmota uns connecten auf die Steckdosenleiste, genau und die gute Frage
ist eh warum nicht, das ist die richtige Frage, ja eine Steckdosenleiste braucht eine Cloud,
jaja natürlich, wenn du dir China Chinesen Zeug kaufst, das braucht alles eine Cloud
heutzutage, so Home, also Access Point Passwort, Kekl, mehr verrate ich nicht.
ich hoffe ich habe es nochmal gesaved, sonst muss ich gleich nochmal alles eintippen,
ich glaube ich habe mich verschrieben Leute, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal ob es funktioniert,
ich glaube es hat funktioniert, wait a minute, einfach so, vielleicht habe ich es doch nicht
verschrieben, also von der Idee her müsste die IP von der Steckdosenleiste jetzt die
hier sein, musst du nochmal überprüfen, tatsächlich, easy, null, ich dachte ich habe
mich verschrieben, ich habe mich gar nicht verschrieben, ich will mich jetzt ja nicht
beschweren, die leitet Strom weiter, jaja natürlich dafür ist sie da, aber du kannst
sie halt auch remote schalten, du kannst remote schalten über Webinterface MQTT oder wie
du willst, diese Steckdosen einzeln und USB alle 4 auf einmal an und aus, IP Leak schon
wieder, oh nein, ok, Console, NTP Server, müssen wir jetzt setzen, ihr seht wie lahm
das ist, wie lief das Bewerbungsgespräch letzten Monat richtig gut, fand ich gut, also
ich fand den Laden nicht schlecht, ich habe mich mit dem Interviewer verstanden, der hat
bei mir auch schon abends zu dem Stream eingeguckt, das fand ich witzig, ich werde demnächst
irgendwann mal einen Probearbeitstag machen, so, ok das Motor ist am rumspacken, weil ich
kein NTP Server gesetzt habe, das ist PainsChamp, so NTP Server 1, NTP Server 2, NTP Server 3,
ich hoffe der frisst die Commands jetzt und es funktioniert und dann machen wir ein Update,
wie läuft sowas eigentlich, nimmt man sich dann einfach einen Tag Urlaub, nö, ich mache
das montags, montags habe ich eh frei, montags arbeite ich eh nicht, es ist ja kein Probearbeitstag
in dem Sinn, dass ich dafür groß Geld bekommen würde oder da wirklich was arbeite großartig,
das ist, dass man sich das mal anguckt, dass man das Team kennenlernt und die ein oder
anderen Sachen vielleicht auch mal so tut, als würde man was machen und besprechen
und gucken, ob das passt beidseitig, ich glaube nicht, dass ich denen in einem Tag eine neue
Konfigmanagement für ihre Cloud aus dem Boden stampfe oder sowas und dann sage easy,
ja, mache ich in einem Tag. Sagen wir mal, könnte das vielleicht jetzt mal laden hier
so, lade, lade das verdammte Spiel, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, einfach langsam, einfach
langsam as fuck, ohne, also ihr seht jetzt, was es ausmacht, wenn NTP Server geblockt
ist bei TAS Motor, das ist von superschnell bedienbar zu unbenutzbar langsam ohne NTP
Server, wow, nice Hackerman Content, ok, Konsole, hat das jetzt gefressen, ja, guck jetzt ist
er schnell, weil er den NTP Server gefressen hat, ja, alles klar, Zeit ist richtig, Timestone
plus eins ist falsch, also Timestone plus eins ist falsch, wir haben nicht 19.54, sondern
20.54, aber ganz im Ernst, damit kann ich leben, wenn meine Steckdosenleiste ein bisschen
falsch geht, ist in Ordnung, was ist ein NTP Server, das ist ein Netzwerkservice zum Uhrzeit
synchronisieren, hast du auch, hat jeder daheim, wissen die meisten vielleicht nix von, aber
hat jeder, jeder 0815 Router macht NTP mit, also, ich will jetzt nicht über die Details
sprechen, ob das ein Router ist oder ein Multifunktionsgerät oder so, aber, ja, also jeder 0815 Telekom
Router, Fritzbox, sonst was hat ein NTP dabei, genauso wie DNS, also, Config, Activate, Safe,
so, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert, mit Schalten gleich, jawoll, Kunst, klick,
klick, klick, klick, alles klar, Firmware Upgrade, mal gucken, ob das Ding genug Speicherplatz
hat, um direkt das Firmware Upgrade zu machen, werden wir gleich sehen, dass ich nicht den
Zwischenschritt machen muss, wie das letzte Mal, ja, hat funktioniert, nice, ich weiß,
wie ich das Ding nennen werde, ich nenne das Hammer 4 Plus USB, dann weiß ich auch, was
es ist, unreachable, oh no, da ist er wieder, nicht HTTPS, Firefox, was machst du da, Config,
das Ding soll heißen 4 Plus USB, dann weiß ich auch, was es ist, ja, so ist guter Name,
Hammer 4 Head Plus USB, der Router, der synchronisiert sich übers Internet, und mit dem gleichen
Protokoll, wie sich deine Rechnerlokale mit dem Router synchronisieren, eigenes, eigenen
Time Server hat keiner, kann man machen, ja, sogar, sag mal so, in der Anflugschritte,
relativ günstig, du brauchst einen GPS Empfänger, die sind billig, und mit dem GPS Empfänger
hast du ziemlich akkurater Time, und da kannst du das theoretisch selbst machen, aber ganz
im Ernst, but why, es macht keinen Sinn, das selbst zu machen, ist komplett unsinnig,
warum sollte man das selbst machen, also es geht, es geht relativ günstig, aber es macht
keinen Sinn, also wenn du einen GPS Empfänger hast, hast du automatisch auch genaue Zeit.
So, was muss man jetzt noch setzen, Config Template, so das Ding heißt nicht TAS Motor,
sondern wie habe ich das genannt, Hammer, jetzt müsste ich es eigentlich anders benennen,
weil das ja die Inventar Nummer war, von dem anderen, das ist eine ziemlich bescheuerte
Nummer, so, USB, save, du kannst übrigens deinen Rechner auch mit NTP Server im Internet
synchronisieren, also es ist nicht so, als müsstest du das über deinen Router machen,
aber die meisten Router werden sich wahrscheinlich als NTP per DHCP verteilen, vermute ich mal,
ja das ist Schwachsinn, man muss das nicht selber machen, so, easy, also wenn man weiß,
wie es funktioniert, ist es doch wirklich nicht schwer gewesen, oder Leute, wir haben
jetzt 5 Minuten gebraucht, das Ding zu flashen, zu aktualisieren auf die aktuelle TAS Motor
Version, es ordentlich zu beschriften und fertig, jetzt könnte man das mit zwei Befehlen
ins Home Automation System einbinden, was ich euch nicht zeigen kann, weil ich da zu viel
private Sachen drin stehen hab, ich könnte jetzt hier irgendein Home Assistant oder so
hochfahren, aber das lohnt sich nicht, wobei wir hätten eine Home Assistant VM, machen
wir mal, man schadet ja nichts, können wir uns ja noch schnell machen, ich weiß halt
nicht, wie aktuell das ist, es kann sein, dass ich das mal updaten muss, können wir
machen, ist wie gesagt easy, dann zeige ich euch auch mal, wie einfach das ist, die Steckdosen
leistet jetzt in sein Smart Home einzubinden, ich muss aber vorher erstmal ein Update vom
Home Assistant, von der Home Assistant VM machen, weil die ist, die hatte ich 3 Monate
nicht an, die hat wahrscheinlich uralt Versionen auch drauf, machen wir das, machen wir das
einfach gerade mal, schadet doch nichts, so, und ansonsten, also flashtechnisch passt
das, ich hab jetzt noch 2 weitere im Schrank liegen, wie gesagt, ich glaube das wollt ihr
euch nicht noch angucken, dass ich das ganze 2 mal mach, dass ich das ganze noch 2 mal
mache, also ich hab den Home Assistant nicht auf Raspberry Pi, ich hab das auf ne x86
Kiste.
Was ist an dem Ding anders, dass es nicht mal mit der China Cloud verbunden ist, ja,
das ist fast der wichtigste Punkt, aber es läuft ne komplett andere Firmware drauf als
original, also dieses Web Interface, was du hier jetzt siehst, das gibt es normalerweise
gar nicht, normalerweise gibt es nur die offizielle App und die China Cloud, und die offizielle
App steuert über die China Cloud seine Steckdose, sowas hier, Web Interface, MQTT Integration
und sowas, vergiss es, gibt es nicht, hat es standardmäßig nicht, entweder bist du
glücklich mit der China Cloud oder nicht und gescheit in deine Heimautomatisierung einbinden
kannst du es natürlich auch nicht, was hat das Ding für ne IP gekriegt, 2.132 ok, Home
Assistant hat 8, 123 ok, Admin 123 hoffe ich mal, wenigstens bin ich mir treu, wenigstens
bin ich mir treu, was meine super Five Head Benamung angeht von Passwörtern, so Configuration,
wir haben mal kurz ein Update, boah das ist ja uralt, Alter dieser Home Assistant ist
ja uralt, was ist denn das für ne Version, das ist ja antik, November 2029, das ist ja
uralt, ok das muss man mal schnell updaten, wir brauchen kein Backup, entweder es geht
kaputt oder es funktioniert, warum connecte die App nicht direkt mit der Steckdose, das
musste die China Chinesen fragen, wahrscheinlich hat es zwei Gründe, erstens wollen sie deine
Daten haben und vielleicht möchte die chinesische Regierung irgendwie mal nen Botnetz haben
mit paar Millionen Leuten, aber der offensichtliche Grund ist, ich gehe davon aus, also der nicht
so verschwörungsmäßige Grund ist, das ist, dass du deine Steckdosenleister aus dem Internet
steuern kannst, weil bestimmt viele Leute sagen, ah dann kann ich aus dem Urlaub ja
keine Ahnung den Kaffeekocher ein und ausschalten oder so, ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich ein
oft benutzter Anwendungsfall ist, aber ich glaube das ist ein Anwendungsfall den die
Hersteller gerne verkaufen als tolle Möglichkeit, ja und damit hast du quasi direkt, genau Alexa
Integration und so ein Crap, damit hast du halt direkt die Möglichkeit ohne irgendwas
selbst zu konfigurieren aus dem Internet drauf zuzugreifen, aber ganz ehrlich ich möchte
nicht aus dem Internet auf meine Steckdosenleister zugreifen, wobei es wie gesagt wahrscheinlich
umgedreht ist, die Steckdosenleiste ist subscribed zu irgendeinem Websocket und kriegt es dann
geschickt, also ich glaube nicht, dass man direkt aus dem Internet zugreifen kann, aber
trotzdem will ich das, wahrscheinlich nicht, hat das Update jetzt funktioniert, ja Update
hat funktioniert, nice, yes alles updaten, alles updaten und dann zeige ich euch wie
man die Steckdosenleiste super easy integrated in Home Assistant, um nicht zu sagen easy
as fuck integriert, wir warten aber erstmal bis das Ding rebooted ist, dass ich die aktuellste
Version habe.
Du kannst es ja auch selbst machen, wenn du Zugriff von außen brauchst, du brauchst
dir da keine China App für, hat das jetzt den Install gemacht oder nicht?
Ah der rebooted noch ok, alles klar, so da sind wir wieder, wir haben aktuelle Version
drauf, refreshen das ganze mal, stellen fest, dass Home Assistant noch nicht gebootet ist,
Home Assistant ist nicht so schnell beim booten was das angeht und jetzt irgendwann Home Assistant
ist starting, dismiss, ja dann starte mal alter, mach hin, kein Backup, neuesten MQTT Broker
draufhauen, gut ist, so jetzt zeige ich euch wie man die Steckdosenleiste super easy noch
in Home Assistant integriert, weil was hat man davon, wenn die Steckdosenleiste jetzt
schön über das Webinterface steuerbar ist, dann möchte er das ja über seine Smart Home
Lösung machen.
Wir haben im Stream auch schon ESP-866, ESP-32 Firmware selbst gemacht, aber in dem Fall
benutze ich TASMOTA, TASMOTA ist mit so das bekannteste an Custom Firmwares, guck mal,
18.000 Sterne auf GitHub und super aktives Projekt, also was besseres kannst du eigentlich
nicht installieren, ach guck mal, der musste, Leute, von wegen gar nicht so alt, der muss
jetzt nochmal, der muss nochmal upgraden auf 7.6, das war bloß so ein Zwischenschritt,
lull, also muss er nochmal rebooten bis es aktuell ist, ja das ist Ende 2021, bei Home
Assistant tut sich richtig viel, die sind immer BÄM BÄM BÄM neue Versionen am rausprügeln,
oh nochmal installen machen, mittlerweile haben die sogar einen Progress Balken, der
mit der, wahrscheinlich mit der Realität nicht all zu viel zu tun hat, die sind relativ
stable und die haben richtig gute Changelogs vor allem, also du erfährst meistens in
einem Changelog sogar, ob es realistisch ist, dass du noch was machen musst oder nicht,
Sachen gibts, also ich kann echt nicht meckern, Home Assistant ist wirklich das Richtige gewesen,
was ich damals mir ausgesucht hab und ich glaube ich hab Home Assistant, ich wollte
ursprünglich Open Hub verwenden, Java Zeug, MonkaS, da kannte ich mich in dem Bereich
noch nicht so aus und ich glaube damals hat mir auf Twitter, und es könnte der Sebaro
sogar gewesen sein, der CuteMod höchstpersönlich hat geschrieben, warum der nicht Home Assistant
ist, da hab ich mir das angeguckt und wo der steckt, wird mich auch mal interessieren
und seitdem benutze ich das seit 4 Jahren oder so, also nicht diese VM, diese VM hat
ja offensichtlich keine Konfig drinne, aber Home Assistant ist ein bisschen problematisch,
wenn du da ewig nicht aktualisierst, kanns sein, dass du auf einen Schlag halt total
viele Breaking Changes hast aus den letzten 16 Releases, die du nicht gemacht hast, so
hat er jetzt rebooted, dann binden wir jetzt die Steckdosenleiste ein, ne er rebooted noch,
ok, alles gut, rebooted mal ein bisschen schneller, Heimatassistent, Heimatunterstützer, Heimunterstützer,
Heimhelfer, wie kann man das am besten übersetzen, Home Assistant, Zuhause, Zuhausehelfer oder
so, was hast du alles so in deinem Smart Home integriert, boah, da müsste ich jetzt
lange, einiges, ich hab euch ja schonmal so grob paar Sachen gezeigt, aber alles mögliche
von Fensterkontakten bis Steckdosen bis Licht, paar Automatisierungen wie Zugverspätungen,
dass er automatisch den Lüfter im Bad ausschaltet, LED Beleuchtung an der Treppe, bis zum Weihnachtsbaum,
sogar der Weihnachtsbaum ist drinne, so, also, jetzt aber.
Aktuelle Home Assistant, gut, wir haben es geschafft, so, damit man seine Steckdosenleiste
ordentlich in Home Assistant einbinden kann, muss man folgendes machen, man braucht auf
jeden Fall, warte mal, was ist das, Steuerung P, ne, Control P, ne, die hatten doch jetzt
so ein cooles Menü bei Home Assistant, ich hab aber vergessen, Control C, hmm, Control
A, Home Assistant hatten jetzt so ein Schnell-Finde-Menü neuerdings eingebaut, Shift P, ne, Home
Assistant Quick Menu, ne, das mein ich nicht, Control K, nein, Command Menu, ne, Control
S, Menu, vielleicht was mit M, Control M, ne, unmuted hab ich's jetzt, sehr gut, ja,
man braucht das nicht, man kann das auch übers Menü machen, ach, einfach nur C, ach, da
hab ich gesucht, einfach nur C, es ist nicht Control C, einfach nur C, also man kann das
alles auch über die Menüs machen, also, ihr müsst jetzt erst mal zu Integrations und
ihr braucht einen konfigurierten MQTT Service, so, ohne funktioniert's nicht, dann geht ihr
auf das Tasmota von der Steckdosenleiste und tragt hier unter MQTT Settings euren Home
Assistant ein, also, die IP Port ist der Standard MQTT Port, so, save, so, Start, dann guckt
ihr in die Konsole, ob er sich mit MQTT verbinden kann, ob alles gut ist, wenn er dann mal neu
gestartet ist, Failed Connect, das ist schon mal schlecht, können wir mal gucken, ob das
denn überhaupt läuft, Tailed Net, eins, eins, acht, acht, drei, siehste, funktioniert, da
liegt es an der Firewall-Freischaltung, nicht funktioniert, eins, acht, acht, drei, wir
können auch Mosquito Sub oder so machen, hm, also, meine Steckdose kommt zumindest nicht
zu meinem MQTT Server, was wahrscheinlich an Firewall-Regeln liegt, würde ich jetzt mal
vermuten, MQTT, also, ich habs erlaubt, dass das freigeschaltet ist, ja, das war's, das
muss man nur einmal machen, aber, komisch, warum geht das nicht, ist alles Default, ist
alles richtig, mit der Leiste, Tuya Convert, hiermit, mit dem Raspberry Pi, ich weiß nicht,
warum eine Leiste da gerade nicht hinkommt, wenn ich ehrlich bin, achso, vielleicht, ach,
ich bin ja blöd, ich hab keine User eingestellt, ich glaube, ich muss User einstellen, wartet
mal, ich hab keine User eingestellt, ja, Addons, Mosquito MQTT Broker Configuration, ja, ich
glaube, ich hab keine User eingestellt, ruhig mal aus, Host, Topic, ah, ich darf nicht, ok,
User, Admin, Passwort, geht das, ok, das funktioniert, alles klar.
Ich will nicht anonyme Listener erlauben, ich will schon User haben, das muss man nur
einmal machen, User, wo konnte man nochmal Accounts anlegen, hier, Add Person, nee, wartet
mal, wo macht man das nochmal, war das hier in den Settings, Documentation, User, Configuration,
User, User, User, Users, ah ja, genau, also, MQTT, Username, Passwort, kann man sich jetzt
irgendwas ausdenken, ja, Create, alles klar, so, das will ich haben, jetzt geht man in die
Connectos, jetzt müssen wir nämlich noch einstellen, den User für den MQTT Server,
User, MQTT, Passwort, High IQ, 123456, save, so, und jetzt gehen wir in die Konsole und
jetzt sollte die Connection auch funktionieren, Konsole, ja, das sieht gut aus, so, und jetzt
ist das einzige, was wir machen müssen, also das muss man ja nur einmalig einstellen, das
ist ja nicht pro Leiste, sondern einmalig für alle MQTT User, so, und jetzt ist das einzige,
was man machen muss, wenn man eine Tasmota-Leiste hinzufügen will, ihr geht in Integrations,
Add Integration, Tasmota, zack, achso, hab ich schon mal gemacht, hier, haben wir sogar
schon konfiguriert, easy, haben wir sogar schon ein paar Mal angelegt, lull, so, und jetzt
können wir mal gucken, ob es schon auftaucht, da ist sie, easy, ihr müsst nichts machen,
ihr müsst, wenn ihr ab jetzt eine neue Steckdosen-Leiste mit Tasmota habt oder irgendein Tasmota-Gerät,
ihr müsst einfach den MQTT Server eintragen und fertig, mehr müsst ihr nicht machen und
schon habt ihr das gesamte Gerät im Home Assistant drin, guck, ihr könnt jetzt hier
drüber die Leiste schalten, weiß nicht, ob man das sieht, also das war's, also ihr müsst
jetzt bei einer neuen Leiste eigentlich gar nichts mehr machen, das ist super easy mittlerweile,
früher war es ein bisschen komplizierter, ja guckt, ich kann jetzt über meinen Home
Assistant den ganzen Kremplchon schalten, wie ich lustig bin, so, und dementsprechend
kann ich auch einfach in mein Dashboard gehen und diesen ganzen Crap hier mal rausschmeißen,
den keiner braucht, oder besser gesagt wir gehen hier hin, Wohnzimmer, so, Edit, schmeißen
wir mal raus, Edit, Wohnzimmer USB, nein, Qt, Qtchat 1, wollen wir da jetzt haben, so,
Name ist, was weiß ich, Keller, Pie, oh, und das ist hier keine Ahnung, USB, Ups, jetzt
nehm ich eigentlich nur USB, USB, so, und das ist keine Ahnung, dann, was weiß ich,
Keller, Kekl, so, und jetzt habt ihr die Knöppe, save, jetzt passt mal auf, zack, jetzt könnt
ihr sie übers Dashboard steuern, und ihr müsst nix machen außer den MQTT Server ein, kann
man die USB Ports einzeln ansteuern, nein, das funktioniert nicht, du kannst nur, guck
jetzt hab ich USB ausgeschaltet, also das hier ist USB, du kannst nur USB auf einmal
einschalten oder USB auf einmal ausschalten, das Schalten geht übrigens schnell, USB hat
die Lampe leuchtet einfach nur danach, so, und jetzt könnt ihr euch euer Dashboard zusammen
klicken wie ihr wollt mit euren Steckdosen leisten, und das funktioniert einfach, easy,
und man hat die weitere Möglichkeit, wenn man das mal braucht, vielleicht weil die Heumautomatisierung
nicht geht oder irgendwas ist, man kann immer noch übers Webinterface drauf und direkt im
Webinterface das ganze machen, oder wenn gar nix hilft, man kann hingehen und den Schalter
drücken, das geht natürlich auch noch, guck, Schalter einmal gedrückt, erstes, Schalter
zweimal gedrückt, zweites, Schalter dreimal gedrückt, drittes, Schalter viermal gedrückt,
viertes, äh, äh, fünfmal gedrückt, USB, eins, zwei, drei, vier, eins, zwei, drei,
vier, vierter an, erster an, zweiter aus, dritter aus, geht auch, also kannst du übers
Webinterface machen, kannst du über den Knopf machen und kannst jetzt auch über deine Heumautomatisierung
machen und guck, dass ihr auch seht, wie schnell sich das überträgt, ich schalte jetzt mal
hier an, ihr sehts hier oben, zack, und ist direkt an, habt ihr gesehen, guck, also das
ist instant, paar Millisekunden, funktioniert, so, machen wir mal die VM wieder aus, weil
brauchen wir ja nicht, war jetzt ja nur zum zeigen, shutdown, jawoll, shutdown, gibt es
solche Steckdosenleisten noch zu kaufen, ja, und angeblich, angeblich gibt es die auch
noch zu kaufen und die sind noch flashbar, 29 Euro für eine ist jetzt nicht billig,
aber von den Features her, gerade geflasht, gibt es da eigentlich nicht so viel, was da
rankommt, es ist aber halt nix, was in Deutschland hergestellt wird, es ist halt China Ding, und
angeblich sind die hier noch flashbar, normalerweise hätte ich ja gesagt, ich kaufe mir den Kram
über AliExpress, dann kriege ich für den Preis vielleicht zwei oder drei, aber da weiß
man nicht, ob die flashbar sind, weil aktuell sind die ganzen Trio Geräte meistens nicht
mehr over the air flashbar, oder aber gar nicht mehr flashbar, weil komplett anderer
Chip drin ist, das ist WLAN, richtig, du hast die Alternative, es gibt noch ein paar ZigBee
Leisten, beim Lidl zum Beispiel, da brauchst du das Flaschen gar nicht, weil ZigBee ist
ja schon darauf ausgelegt sinnvoll angesteuert zu werden, allerdings können die da natürlich
auch nicht so viel wie TAS Motor mit der ganzen jahrelangen Entwicklung, aber das meiste macht
man eh über seinen Smart Home und nicht direkt über die Steckdosenleiste, übrigens wisst
ihr warum die jetzt blinkt, weil sie die Verbindung verloren hat zum MQTT Server, naja, weil
ich die VM mit dem MQTT Server gerade ausgeschaltet habe, aber von Handschalten, seht ihr, funktioniert
immer noch, yep, so siehts aus Leute, Flashchamp am Start gewesen heute wieder,
ich meine, es wäre natürlich, guck mal, du hast unterschiedliche Farben, den Sinn
habe, verstehe ich nicht so genau ehrlich gesagt, was da der Twitch Chat mir damit sagen
will, aber ok, was wollte ich gerade sagen, keine Ahnung, Boomer Hirn habe ich vergessen,
ne, nicht verbunden, du brauchst Tuya Convert und das Flash die Steckdosenleiste übers W-Lan,
deswegen geht das auch nur mit welchen, die noch alt genug Factory Firmware drauf haben,
weil die neueren haben das gepatcht oder haben eben einen anderen Chip, funktioniert, ja,
alles funktioniert, auch Einbindung in Home Assistant funktioniert, alles gut, kann man
den Raspberry Pi ausmachen, den Switch ausmachen, den Pi ausmachen, alles gut, exellent, so
Chat, gibt es noch irgendwelche Questions, weil nochmal zwei Flaschen will ich jetzt
nicht, das ist auch irgendwie nicht so spannend, nochmal den gleichen Krempel zweimal, es
halt die Sache, man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass die Flashbar sind, aber ganz
im Ernst, ihr könnt es probieren und wenn es nicht geht, dann schickt ihr die einfach
zurück, macht ihr einfach den Insie Modus, aktiviert ihr bei Amazon und sagt, ich schick
das zurück, da merken die ja nichts von, dass ihr die versucht habt zu Flashen, das
ist ja komplett nicht feststellbar, vor allem halt auch wenn es nicht funktioniert hat,
behaltet ihr sie und wenn es nicht funktioniert hat, schickt ihr sie halt zurück, ich meine,
ich will es jetzt nicht promoten, wir dürfen den immer nicht vergessen, wir sind auf einer
Amazon Plattform unterwegs, ja, also sollte ihr natürlich nicht machen, Chat, ganz böse,
also kaputt würde ich die Dinger nicht zurückschicken, also wenn ihr die kaputt macht, Amazon ist
meistens sehr kulant und nimmt die Dinger sogar in teilweise echt fragwürdigem Zustand
entgegen, aber ja, das würde ich da nicht machen, ich meine, wenn man das Ding wirklich
zerstört hat oder selbst kaputt gemacht hat, natürlich könnte man dann immer erzählen
so nach dem Motto, es ging kaputt beim ersten Anschließen und wenn euer Amazon Konto nicht
oft Reklamationen hat, dann machen die das dann wahrscheinlich auch, aber irgendwie ist
es trotzdem ein bisschen fragwürdig, wat, dann das hier, ich hab gerade eine Mail von
OnlyFans bekommen, das ist bestimmt Scam, China-Chinesen, Indischer Scam wahrscheinlich,
OnlyFans, Gachibas, Gachirole, genau, ne, nicht aber abgelaufen, irgendwelche Empfehlungen
oder so, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich diesen Camgirls musst du folgen hier, gib Geld aus
bei uns, ich hab keine OnlyFans Abos, sexy Devops Content, Abos, ne ne ne ne, wenn schon
dann Indie Fox, wobei gibt's die überhaupt noch, ich will jetzt nicht nachgucken, ich
will jetzt nicht nachgucken im Stream, ne ganz ehrlich, OnlyFans ist Geldverschwendung,
wenn man sich diesen Content wirklich angucken will, dann gibt es genug alternative Möglichkeiten
da dran zu kommen, jetzt könnte natürlich jemand sagen, ja aber ich möchte die Creators
unterstützen, kann ich nix dagegen sagen, ich leb ja letztendlich zum Teil auch davon,
dann macht, ja, Twitch, Mason, Dankeschön für den Sub, das klick ich jetzt nicht an,
das werd ich definitiv nicht anklicken, selbst wenn du sagst save for work, ich seh, ich
seh, da gehts um Lüfter, ich hab's gesehen, da gehts um Lüfter, um Ventilatoren gehts
da, das ist natürlich gut, dass sie das Subreddit so gesnackt haben, so einkassiert haben und
dass das jetzt nicht wirklich OnlyFans ist, sondern wirklich OnlyFans, also Fans so, Lüfter
halt, huge Fan, ja gibt es auch irgendwas spannendes, ansonsten würd ich jetzt aufgehen
und mir noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Amazon irgendwie ne Serienfolge oder so angucken,
oh ein Sarix, kennst du das, ne, sagt mir nix, ach doch, das ist Müll, das hab ich
mir angeschaut, das ist Müll, das ist diese Linux-Distro für, diese Linux-Distro für
Bitcoin Miner, die in den Remotes, ungefragten in Remote-VPN aufhacken auf deine Linux-Maschine,
ja, ja, ne, ne, das ist so komisch, kommt mir nicht ins Haus, ja, such mal danach, wenn
ich glaubst, ja, Remotely Access, das ist standardmäßig offen, ja, zwar mit ner random
generated-Ul, die keiner erraten kann, aber ich will sowas nicht standardmäßig haben,
ich würde sagen C-Sharp und ist immer noch meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache, tja, würd
ich mir mal Gedanken machen, ich hab dich nicht gesehen, du hast überhaupt nix geschrieben
weiter oben, wie gesagt, ich hab nicht groß jetzt die wahnsinns Bewerbungsschreibaktion
gemacht, ich hatte ein Vorstellungsgespräch, eins hab ich noch und ein Probearbeitstag
demnächst, ansonsten erstmal nix, mal gucken, 2023 wird das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, ja
vielleicht in WSL, alles klar Leute, gut, also, wenn es dann sonst nix mehr gibt, dann,
nein, kennste, muss ich das nochmal anmachen, das hab ich schon ausgemacht, jetzt muss ich
es nochmal anmachen, ist mein VM jetzt abgekackt oder was, mach meine VM hier, VM, VM, was
ist, ah, ok, alles klar, VM macht Betge, ja, so siehts aus, VM hat sich wohl auf SSD
geschrieben, gerade 16GB, du bist drin, ok, wie hast du das gemacht, beim ausgeschaltet
drin zu sein, aber, gut, ich mein, der Chat da kann das, er kann auch ausgeschaltete Rechner
hacken, das ist überhaupt kein Ding, der Chat macht das easy.
Easy, macht er das, easy, gut, dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream, Leute, ich hoffe,
euch hat's gefallen, bis denn, macht's gut, see you.